your concern was that a labor government
might sort of re racialize Britain
you're saying that what you fear is an
era where your skin color becomes more
important I think you quoted Martin
Luther King talking about how he looked
forward to a day where the character was
judged ahead of a color of the skin do
you now think this is being reversed so
look at look at what K Arma tweeted the
labor is going to be bringing in a new
race equality act what's going in that
we already have an equality act and race
is one of the protected characteristics
so what are they solving for what is the
thing that they going to bring in that
is not here we have to probe these
things what will go in a labor race
equality Act is all the stuff that they
keep asking me they want things like
mandatory ethnicity pay gaps to mirror
gender pay gaps even though race is not
binary and it is not equally present
across the population the way that men
and women are 50% so companies would
have to go through all their employees
they'd have to do that what what works
in London will not necessarily work in
North Umbria so using these crude
techniques to carry out social
engineering very very dangerous